tradition hearing of wikileaks founder
julian assange in london's begun
it had been postponed for months because
the coronavirus locked down leaving
assange all that time
waiting in jail let's go live to sharjah
edwards dashed he was outside the court
charlie um i think you said you saw
maybe uh mr assange going behind you
into court earlier on so
we think it's all started today all eyes
on this yeah
absolutely it's a huge day for truth and
justice as wikileaks founder julian
assange
is in court today here at the old bailey
in central london for his hearing
proceedings that will ultimately decide
whether or not he is extradited to the
united states now the hearings
were supposed to go on much earlier this
year but were pushed back due to the
covert 19 pandemic
now as you say just a few uh minutes ago
i saw
the van carrying julian assange enter
into the criminal court as well as that
we've also seen
june assange's father enter the criminal
court as well through the back uh
entrance as well as his partner stella
morris has just recently become
very vocal in the campaign just before
she entered the criminal court she was
pleading
for his release it's quite noisy outside
the old bailey here in central london
many protesters and activists here too
are pleading for his immediate release
so today
really opens the newest chapter in
almost a decade-long
attempt of the united states to try and
prosecute
julian assange they call it one of the
largest compromises of classified
information in the history
of the united states and so the us have
now indicted him under 18 counts under
the
espionage act and want him to face trial
for spying
and publishing classified documents all
related to the war in iraq
and afghanistan plus one of conspiracy
to hack a government computer to then
publish these documents so this journey
to court here today has been a very
tumultuous one for julian assange of
course he was going back into the public
eye
last april in 2019 when he was
infamously hauled out of london's
ecuadorian embassy by british police
where he was seeking
political asylum there he then began
serving a 50-week sentence at the belmar
prison for skipping bail back in 2012.
even though he has now served that
sentence he was still
kept in belmar prison equating to around
one and a half years before any evidence
was even
presented in court so this prolongation
of imprisonment is one of julian
assange's legal team's
main point of defense not just for an
obstruction of justice but also his
deteriorating health
over the past few years he's been in and
out of the medical award
at belmar prison so the team would argue
that julian assange is not in a fit
state to face trial
in the united states they will also
contend though that the u.s
is seeking to prosecute julian assange
for political
offences and therefore that would then
exempt him from extradition
under the uk u.s extradition treaty
however
prosecutors would actually argue that
these were not political offences and
that he in fact
endangered lives by publishing these
classified documents so it's a very
complex case that will be all looked
through this case will be going on for
the next
four weeks or so that will eventually
decide on julia and sanjay's fate
the campaign is outside the old bayley
here today
very vocal in saying that he is a
valiant campaigner
for truth and justice and they argue
that it's not just you and assange and
the doc here today but also
freedom of press is also in the doc as
well as the public's right to access
information if june assange is
extradited that will silence him
but it will also gag other journalists
and spread a climate of fear of
journalists and media
worldwide as well so for press freedom
today the stakes are incredibly high
yeah so much mistake on either side of
it isn't it and how noisy is that there
today all right
come back to us if anything kicks off
let us know what's happening throughout
the day yeah shout out here for now
goodbye
you